When it comes to the big day,...
...we'll label and check your pet into our dedicated animal zone...
...and make sure that they're perfectly fit to fly.
Inside, it's fully air-conditioned, heated and ventilated.
Most importantly, it's calm and peaceful so there's no need to worry.
They're in safe hands and you can come all the way to the doors to say goodbye.
When it's time to board, one of our dedicated animal vehicles...
...will chauffeur your pet to the aircraft.
They'll be the last on and the first off,...
...ensuring that there's minimum exposure to any hustle and bustle outside.
Before boarding, our captains are notified of our feathered, furry and fishy passengers on board,...
...and they'll set a comfortable temperature so that they feel right at home.
Once in the air, it's time to relax and enjoy the flight.
On board, it's nice and peaceful,...
...allowing your pet to relax and snooze throughout the journey.
When the plane lands, we know you'll be eager to see them.
But we're almost there.
It's just a short journey from the aircraft to the animal zone before you're finally reunited.